so you mentioned building blocks
uh you didn't mention the word god
um or sort of the afterlife are those
essential
to the myth so there's a contact
experience is there some other aspects
of myth and religion which makes them
viral
which makes them spread and captivate
the imagination
of people yes is there a pattern
to them i think that for each era
it's different and people have first
let's talk about the definition of
religion if that's okay because
most people assume the definitions that
we in the west are familiar with which
is that you know that of
christianity islam um judaism
you know monotheistic religions and
there are
that's not i mean those are just some
religions there are so many different
types of religions
some religions have no god at all zen
buddhism for example is a religion
that asks you to take away
your belief structures like to kind of
like in fact i would call that a kantian
type religion
right and that it's it's basically
telling you to get rid of your concept
concepts of what you think about things
so that you can actually have the
experience
like you were talking about earlier of
the thing in itself and they call that
satori
so there are people who believe you know
they try
to they call it meditations and
meditation
um and it's fairly radical actually um
in some monasteries
i don't know if they still do this but
they'll whack you on the head
if you appear to be um
not focusing and you know that kind of
thing you know they do things to
basically take
you away from your conceptions of
reality
and bring you into a state of
all that is which is what they call
satori and that has nothing to do with
god
i like this religion anything that
involves sticks and whacking
in order for you to focus better i'm
gonna have to join a monastery so
okay so this so uh digging into
definitions of religion so like what is
what do you think
is the scope that defines a religion
oh okay so in my field we have a but a
few different definitions of religion as
you can imagine just like philosophers
have
different definitions of what is real um
so i take this definition and it comes
from john livingston
and it's um religion is that set of
beliefs and practices
um that determine that is inspired by a
transformative
what is perceived actually to be a
transformative
and sacred power can you say that again
yeah
so religion is a set of it's not just
belief it's also practices it's both
belief and practices because you won't
have the practices
without the belief so you have those
together okay
and it's inspired by what is perceived
because we don't know if it's real or
not
what is perceived to be of sacred and
transforming power
so perceived by the followers or is this
connected to the original sort of
experience no no it well
it's it's perceived by the followers
that's a really good definition so
and that's the governing idea is that
there's something
of great power yes perceived to be of
great power
to which you can connect yourself either
emotionally or intellectually
somehow in order to explore the world
that is beyond your own capabilities
yes and is there communication also
involved
or generally yeah yeah that's a great
definition okay
so within that falls everything that
we've uh
we've talked about so far including
technology and
alien life and so on
you